individual states often drop the ball
majorly when it comes to reporting to
the federal background check system when
there are people that should not be
getting guns because they shouldn't be
able to pass background checks we now
have a story of sort of the opposite
which is the federal background check
data or database not being used by
states that are supposed to use it this
comes from Florida we've just learned
that there were hundreds of permits
issued and thousands of people who
applied for concealed carry permits in
Florida who never had the background
checks that were supposed to be done
with the federal system all because an
employee of Florida state government
couldn't log into the system
Florida's inspector general did a report
about this the details of which were
only now learning it's an employee of
Florida's division of Licensing named
Lisa wild she quite literally just
couldn't log into the system and do the
background checks and it took a very
very long time for anything to be done
about it in fact it took a full year
until March of 2017 for something at the
Bureau of Licensing to be done once they
realized that hey federal records
weren't being reviewed by the Florida
system and the report that was released
says that Lisa wild was negligent in not
sending over the background checks and
of course everybody now is saying it's
just Lisa wilds fault which to me is
absolutely ridiculous
she was negligent because she should
have communicated hey there's hundreds
or thousands of these checks were
supposed to be doing and I can't log in
she should have done that but how do you
leave something of such importance who
can legally have a gun right this is a
really important issue how do you leave
that to a system that has no triggers or
monitoring or something that would
identify that hey the background checks
aren't happening and it is a much bigger
problem than just Lisa Wilde and this is
all so stupid that people are writing to
me and saying David do you believe that
this was really an oversight don't you
think that maybe this was a concerted
effort not to do background checks and I
go back to I forget who
up with this phrase originally never
never attribute malice to that which can
be explained adequately by stupidity I
know I'm slightly off with the wording
and I don't remember who the quote comes
from there are some bits of information
that might suggest that there was some
deliberate looking the other way but we
don't actually have evidence that this
was malice it really appears to have
been stupidity and a disastrous system a
few mitigating factors because I know
that there are people who will
understandably be upset with me if I
don't mention this that make this
slightly less bad than originally
reported number one there are other
background check systems other than the
ni CS you're supposed to use ni CS but
you can still run other background
checks as a state like the state of
Florida number two I do want to restate
that this was for concealed carry permit
specifically not more generally for gun
purchases but for people who
specifically wanted to concealed carry
and number three after they learned
about this Florida did revoke
three-hundred concealed weapons permits
so there are some slight mitigating
factors here in terms of how bad this
was but how is I couldn't log in and on
an even remotely acceptable explanation
for anything related to guns for the
period of a year and I also am curious
how Lisa Wilde continued to work her job
in good standing given that this was
going on and I'm curious what her other
duties were the entire thing stinks and
this really goes back you know there's
an argument that we hear from the write
about gun safety regulations which is we
don't need more regulations we just need
to enforce some of the ones we have and
I completely agree with that but we've
seen no actual effort or demand from the
gun fetishists to make sure that we are
enforcing the gun safety regulations
that we have
I'm fully on board with that we have a
ton of gun safety regulations that could
mitigate some of the gun violence
problem that we're having in this
country but the people who are saying no
new gun safety regulations and force the
ones that we have are doing absolutely
nothing to make sure
that happens if I'm missing something on
this story if you think I'm wrong in my
reporting and my criticism of what went
on here let me know this story and all
the other stories we talked about today
are up for discussion on our subreddit
at david pakman.com /re d di t quick
break
Andrew Torres joins me next